europa intenta a toda costa combatir la
crisis energética desatada por la guerra
en ucrania por lo que busca en otros
países el gas que le hará falta si rusia
cierra definitivamente el grifo una
amenaza que la compañía reiteró a uno de
los mayores importadores de alemania en
una carta que declaró el estatus de
fuerza mayor por déficit de suministro
de gas la empresa rusa gazprom cerró las
válvulas del gasoducto nord stream 1
desde el 11 de julio argumentando el
mantenimiento en una turbina
níjar que al día de hoy no hay solución
al problema de equipamiento que se está
produciendo en la estación de
compresores de puerto vaya todavía no
hay ninguna solución una total cobra
mientras el kremlin podría incumplir sus
compromisos de combustible con los 27 en
respuesta a la lluvia de sanciones por
invadir el país de volodymyr selenski
azerbayán ya dio el sí a un acuerdo que
duplicará las importaciones a la unión
europea entre proyecciones y el proyecto
energético iniciado por azerbaiyán y
respaldado por la unión europea y
respaldado por nuestros socios cambia
completamente el mapa energético de
europa en playstation el mar
por lo tanto la unión europea decidió
diversificarse más allá de rusia y
recurrir a más a socios más confiables y
me complace contar con azerbaiyán entre
ellos aunque se vayan manden por su
parte el primer ministro italiano mario
draghi de visita en argelia logró
aumentar el suministro de gas en 4000
millones de metros cúbicos para
solventar la crisis y francia
garantizará el suministro de gasóleo en
un acuerdo con los emiratos árabes
unidos con el jeque mohamed bin zayed al
nahyan quien llegó a parís este lunes
pero en berlín donde empezó la
conferencia de cambio climático antesala
de la cumbre del clima el canciller
alemán olaf scholz advirtió que la
guerra en ucrania está alejando el mundo
de la descarbonización tendrá sus listas
y aranda lo que no debe pasar nos ahora
es que nos deslicemos hacia un
renacimiento global de la energía fósil
y del carbón en particular
el reloj sigue corriendo de cara al
invierno europeo